اكتشاف واعد في مجال الطب فحص دم بسيط جدا
يكشف عن 50 نوعا من الاورام السرطانيه
اختبار الدم يسمى بالخزع السائله يمكن ان
يتحرى عن الخلايا السرطانيه لدى اشخاص
ترتفع عندهم مخاطر الاصابه بهذا المرض لان
نجاح علاج الورم يعتمد بشكل كبير على
اكتشافه في مراحل مبكره بالفعل الانجاز
الطبيه لجامعه تحدثت عن اوساط علميه وعرضت
نتائج في هذه الخدمات الصحيه في هيئه عفوا
الخدمات الصحيه في بريطانيا
ووافق التجربه التي طبقت على اكثر من 5000
نجح الاختبار في تحديد موقع ومصدر السرطان
بنحو 85%
والله هذا شيء رائع يعني انجاز عن جد رائع
انه تقدر تعمل فحص حتى يكشف لك حتى لو ما
عندك اي اعراض او اي شيء رائع دائما حتى
بعض الدكاتره حينما مثلا يجري الان عمليه
منظار للمعده اذا كنت تشكين يرى بعض
المؤشرات على انه هذا الامر قد يتطور الى
ان يصبح خلايا سرطانيه او انه تصبح لديك
يعني احتماليه حدوث السرطان فينصحك باجراء
هذه بعض التحليلات والعمليات هذه قفزه
كبيره لانه ممكن تقدر تعرف اذا في استعداد
لخلايا سرطانيه في اي مكان في الجسم مش
بمكان معين لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات